Ha llegado la hora de resolver
desigualdades pero,
desigualdades con valor absoluto
y muchos comentarios acerca de las desigualdades
con valor absoluto,
es que es la parte mas difícil de toda la álgebra,
sin embargo
usando todo
lo que hemos aprendido hasta ahorita de
ecuaciones con valor absoluto,
vas a ver que no es tan difícil como se piensa,
lo único que necesitamos es recordar,
todo lo que hemos visto, así que déjenme empezar
con una desigualdad bastante sencilla.
El valor absoluto de "x" es menor que 12
y recuerda que una de las formas
en las que veíamos el valor absoluto,
era como la distancia,
la distancia que
teníamos de un cierto número al 0,
es decir,
que otra forma de ver esta desigualdad,
es pensar en los números cuya
distancia al 0 sea menor que 12.
Así que déjame hacer aquí una recta numérica
y aquí voy a poner el 0,
y lo que estoy buscando son los números que estén
a una distancia menor de 2 unidades del 0,
y si te das cuenta, son todos estos,
si yo pongo aquí el 12 y aquí el -12,
todos los números
cuya distancia al 0 es menor que 12,
pues son todos estos
que estoy tomando aquí,
todos, todos estos,
porque por ejemplo si tomo el 1, el 1 tiene una distancia al 0 menor que 12 unidades,
si por ejemplo me tomo el 11,
el 11 está a una distancia
del 0 menor que 12 unidades
y así me puedo seguir
con todos estos números de aquí,
es decir, que otra forma de ver esto
son todas las "x"
que son mayores que -12,
date cuenta que son las
"x" que son más grandes que -12,
pero no todas,
tenemos que pararle hasta que llegamos al 12,
es decir,
vamos a tomarnos todas las
"x" que son mayores que el -12
y además,
todas las "x" que son menores que 12,
que se cumplan estas dos igualdades
simultáneamente,
que seamos mayores que -12
y menores que 12,
como por ejemplo el -3,
el -3 es más grande que -12,
pero es menor que 12
y por lo tanto la distancia que hay
del -3 al 0 es menor que 12,
y así podemos pensar en
todos estos números, que por cierto,
si esto mismo lo vemos
una noción de intervalos,
yo podría decir que
el intervalo solución de esta desigualdad
es de -12 a 12 en paréntesis,
porque recuerda
que no tocamos al 12 ni al -12,
por que tanto el 12 como el -12
están a una distancia
igual a 12 unidades, del 0
e inclusive también lo podemos poner de esta forma,  -12 es menor que "x" menor que 12.
Estas son las tres formas de escribir
la solución de esta desigualdad,
y fíjate que es bastante sencillo
si nosotros pensamos
en la distancia que tenemos al 0,
así que vamos a ver otro ejemplo.
El valor absoluto de 7x
es mayor o igual a 21,
es decir,
nos estamos fijando en los números
tales que la distancia que hay al 0 multiplicada por 7,
sea mayor o igual a 21,
o lo podemos ver así,
lo que está adentro del valor absoluto,
es decir 7x,
si nos fijamos en lo que está dentro
del valor absoluto,
y nos tomamos la distancia al 0,
tiene que ser mayor o igual a 21,
por lo tanto,
la idea y la noción es la misma,
así que déjame hacer una recta numérica,
voy a poner aquí el 0,
aquí el 21, y aquí el -21
y me estoy preguntando
por algo que la distancia
al 0 sea mayor que 21,
es decir, lo que está dentro del valor absoluto,
quiero que tenga una distancia
mayor a 21 al 0,
por lo tanto lo que estoy diciendo es que me voy a fijar en todos los números que están aquí,
es decir, todos los números menores que -21,
todos los números menores que -21,
y de hecho vamos a tocar el -21,
pues es mayor o igual, es decir,
también estamos aceptando las distancias
que estén a 21 unidades del 0,
y fíjate,
cualquier número que tomemos aquí,
cualquier número que sea menor que -21,
por ejemplo el -30,
está una distancia mayor
que 21 unidades del 0,
y también todos estos de aquí,
del 21 en adelante,
incluyendo el 21
por que mi desigualdad es mayor o igual.
Por ejemplo si tomamos el 40, el 40 está
a una distancia mayor o igual a 21 unidades del 0,
y bueno ya que tenemos
estos dos posibles intervalos
entonces fíjate,
si me tomo cualquier número aquí,
en esto que estoy subrayando de verde,
esto quiere decir que 7x
tiene que ser menor o igual que -21,
es decir, me estoy fijando en todos los números
que sean menores o iguales a -21,
o en su dado caso,
7x tiene que ser mayor o igual a 21
lo que está dentro del valor absoluto,
tiene que ser mayor o igual que 21,
pues todos los números que
son mayores o iguales que 21,
tienen una distancia
más grande o igual al 0 que 21 unidades,
¡y perfecto!
Ya que tenemos estas dos desigualdades
7x menor o igual a -21
o en su dado caso
7x mayor o igual a -21
podemos,
de cada una de ellas despejar a "x"
utilizando las propiedades de las desigualdades.
Y recuerda aquí
lo más importante es ver
que lo que está dentro de mi valor absoluto,
lo que sea que esté adentro,
cumpla mi desigualdad,
es decir fijémonos en las distancias,
y bueno, si divido ambos lados entre 7
¿qué me va a quedar?
Pues 7x entre 7 me da "x",
mientras que la desigualdad se conserva,
y me queda "x" menor o igual a -21 entre 7 que es -3,
ó en su dado caso en la otra desigualdad,
me queda que "x" es mayor o igual a 3,
es decir, 21 entre 7,
pues la desigualdad se conserva
¡Y ya está!
Tengo ya el conjunto solución de todas las "x"
que cumplen esta desigualdad con valor absoluto,
todas las "x" que son
menor o igual a -3
ó en su dado caso, todas
las "x" que son mayores o iguales a 3,
es más,
déjame ponerte una recta numérica,
para que veamos las soluciones
¡Y ojo!
La recta numérica que puse aquí arriba
fue la que nos ayudó a entender el problema
de mi desigualdad con valor absoluto,
sin embargo,
esta recta numérica que estoy poniendo de rojo,
este de aquí,
es mi intervalo solución,
de este problema,
de esta desigualdad.
Todas las "x" que son
mayores o iguales que 3
todas estas que estoy poniendo aquí,
y también
todas las "x"
que son menores o iguales a -3 y ya está.
Ya tenemos la solución
de otra desigualdad con valor absoluto
y date cuenta, que si nosotros pensamos en distancias, no es tan difícil,
así que bueno,
vamos a hacer otro par de ejemplos,
para que vayamos agarrando más práctica,
y te des cuenta que no son
tan difíciles ni imposibles de resolver.
Así que tomemos otro ejemplo,
me voy a tomar el valor absoluto
¿De quién?
Se me ocurre tomar el valor absoluto de 5x más 3,
5x más 3,
y esto lo voy a hacer menor que 7,
y entonces ya va a ser mucho más rápido
y mucho más fácil,
porque estamos buscando algo,
es decir, lo que está dentro del valor absoluto,
quiero que cumpla,
que su distancia al 0 sea menor que 7
y entonces, si hacemos una recta numérica
¿De qué me estoy refiriendo?.
Si aquí tengo al 0,
y por acá tengo al 7
y por acá tengo al -7,
también se va a cumplir que necesito todos
los números que estén en este intervalo,
por que todos los números
que están en ese intervalo,
su distancia al 0 es menor que 7,
y por lo tanto me queda que 5x más 3,
esto, tiene que ser
en primer lugar mayor que -7,
estoy buscando todas las "x"
que cumplan que
5x más 3 sea mayor que -7,
y a su vez,
al mismo tiempo se tiene que cumplir
que 5x más 3 sea menor que 7,
es decir,
para que estemos en este intervalo solución,
estamos buscando las "x" que cumplan
simultáneamente estas dos desigualdades,
y por lo tanto,
si ya tengo estas 2  desigualdades,
entonces me puedo poner a resolverlas,
por ejemplo aquí,
yo tengo 5x es mayor que
-7 menos 3, es decir -10,
pase el 3 del otro lado con signo contrario,
y después, si divido ambos lados entre 5, me queda que "x" es mayor que -2.
Aquí me queda que 5x
debe ser menor que 7 menos 3, lo cual es 4,
y si divido todo entre 5 me queda que
"x" tiene que ser menor que 4/5,
o dicho de otra manera,
como se tiene que cumplir
ambas desigualdades al mismo tiempo,
mi conjunto solución va a ser del -2 al 4/5,
abierto
pues mi desigualdad no era menor o igual,
era menor estricto y bueno,
ya que tenemos esto,
entonces quiero que lo visualices
de la siguiente manera,
"x" está en el intervalo entre -2 y 4/5,
es decir,
que -2 es menor que "x" menor que 4/5,
o lo podemos ver también en su forma gráfica,
sin embargo ya verlo en su forma gráfica,
es muy sencillo,
ya sabes cómo lo podemos ver,
estamos buscando las "x"
que estén entre -2 y 4/5
por que al final lo que estamos haciendo
es que se cumplan
ambas desigualdades al mismo tiempo,
y quiero que te des cuenta,
que ya podemos como,
visualizar una regla para estas desigualdades,
si me tomo el valor absoluto de "f" de "x"
esto menor que "a",
entonces date cuenta que caemos en este mismo ejemplo, y este mismo ejemplo terminamos diciendo,
que esto que tenemos aquí,
es exactamente lo mismo
que tomarnos a "f" de "x"
en el intervalo entre -a y "a",
a todas las "x" que cumplan
que la distancia de "f" de "x" sea menor que "a",
y por lo tanto,
estamos atrapados entre dos valores,
entre el valor de "-a"
y el valor de "a"
"-a" menor que "f" de "x" menor que "a",
o dicho de otra manera "f" de "x"
es mayor que -a
y a su vez, simultáneamente
"f" de "x" es menor que "a",
esto es justo como lo estábamos viendo,
esto en el caso
de que tengamos el valor absoluto de algo,
menor que "a",
si tenemos al revés, el valor absoluto de algo
es mayor que "a",
lo que estoy buscando son distancias
que estén mucho más lejos que "a",
estamos buscando las "x"
que cumplan que la distancia de f de "x" al 0,
sea mucho más grande que "a",
y si recuerdas el ejemplo pasado,
solamente pasa cuando
"f" de "x" es más grande que "a".
Esto tiene toda la lógica del mundo,
o en su dado caso,
f de "x" es menor que "-a"
porque cualquier valor que te tomes,
menor que "-a"
cualquier valor que te tomes
menor que "-a",
va a estar a una distancia
más lejos que "-a" del 0,
y fíjate que aquí hay una gran diferencia.
En el primer caso,
en el caso de verde,
estamos pidiendo
que las desigualdades se cumplan
simultáneamente,
al mismo tiempo,
"f" de "x" mayor que "-a"
y "f" de "x" menor que "a",
mientras que en el caso de amarillo,
en nuestro segundo caso,
lo que buscamos es que pase una
o la otra, o que "f" de "x" sea
más grande que "a",
o en su dado caso,
que "f" de "x" sea menor que "-a",
así que con esta reglita, que no sería muy bueno
que te la aprendieras de memoria,
vamos a intentar hacer un siguiente ejercicio.
Recuerda que es mucho más importante que
tú entiendas de donde sale el concepto,
y a mí me gusta mucho pensarlo
con el concepto de distancia,
así que me voy a tomar el siguiente ejercicio,
el valor absoluto
de 2/7 de "x" esto más 9,
quiero que sea mayor que 5/7,
2x entre 7 más 9
en valor absoluto,
quiero que sea mayor que 5/7
y bueno vamos a usar esta regla
que estamos utilizando,
quiero que 2x entre 7 más 9,
el valor absoluto de esto
sea mayor que 5/7
entonces, tenemos 2 casos,
o que 2x entre 7 más 9
sea más grande que 5/7,
este sería nuestro primer caso,
o en su dado caso ¡y ojo!
es, o en su dado caso,
2x entre 7 más 9
esto sea menor que -5/7,
porque fíjate, si nosotros nos tomamos
cualquier cosa que sea menor que -5/7,
y tomamos su valor absoluto,
su valor absoluto
va a ser más grande que 5/7,
así que ya está, ya tengo aquí mis dos desigualdades
que tenemos que resolver
y bueno, como ya tengo dos desigualdades que resolver, qué te parece si,
para quitarnos de problemas
multiplicamos todo primero por 7,
me queda 2x más 63,
esto es mayor que 5,
y 2x más 63,
esto es menor que -5,
9 por 7 es 63,
y bueno,
ahora vamos a despejar la "x"
y para esto voy a pasar este 63 del otro lado restando,
y me queda que 2x
va a ser más grande que
5 menos 63 lo cual es 58... 58
mientras que de este lado me queda que
2x es menor que -5 menos 63,
lo cual es -68... -68...
y 2x es menor que -68
y 2x es mayor que -58,
aquí me falto un menos, perdón,
y ahora voy a dividir ambos lados
de cada una de estas desigualdades
entre 2,
para que ya me quede el valor de "x" despejado,
en la primera desigualdad me queda que "x" es mayor que -58 entre 2, lo cual me da -29,
-29,
ya tengo aquí mi primer intervalo solución,
o en su dado caso,
también podría ser que
"x" sea menor que -68 entre 2,
que es -34...-34.
¡Perfecto! Ya tengo mis 2 intervalos soluciones
¿y cómo se van a ver estos
intervalos en mi recta numérica?
Así que déjame dibujar una recta numérica,
y vamos a ver qué nos está diciendo esta información.
Aquí tengo el -29,
por acá tengo el -34,
y yo lo que quiero son
las "x" que cumplan que van a ser mayores que -29,
¡y ojo! El intervalo sea abierto por que no toca el 29, todas estas de aquí... todas estas aquí...
esto es por una parte,
o en su dado caso, también cumplen
aquellas "x" que son menores que -34 abierto entonces, todas estas de aquí.
Cualquier "x" que te tomes en este intervalo,
va a cumplir con esta desigualdad.